My right bulb hasn't been lighted up the last three nights the nightly program runs as door will but no light no sound from the bomb you know it's happening.
That's not good so if you're light if you're right light isn't lighting up it. I then it's you're not getting the frequencies.
So did the cord get pinched somehow did it get pulled out somehow is it that plugged in all the way do you have it switched to bomb make sure it's not actually switched to that.
Those are the things you want to look at.
You know the bulbs typically don't burn out but they can become damaged.
And you know most common damages we've seen it just happens to get you know the solder got broken on it.
That will have to go back to true right to be replaced I can't fix a bold problem.
And you might just need to order a new one from true right.
Not self fixable that way. So you can't reset if you broke the solder you can't resolder has to be a special type of solder and such.
If you're not getting the frequencies of pure bulb is not ready.